Then there are the patients that know the CS. There are the ones that are in this third phase.
The third phase is when the patient has moved into having an autoimmune disorder.
So we have to talk a little bit about the immune system. Are you still with me?
So that you can understand what an autoimmune disease is.
So who knows what an autoimmune disease is? What's an autoimmune disease?
So if you google autoimmune disease, I got to learn about autoimmune disease.
It's going to say when your body attacks cell tissue.
But we want to expand that a little bit so we can understand what that really is.
So it's not your body attacking cell tissue.
Well, it's actually your immune system that's attacking cell tissue.
Well, it's actually more specific than that.
It's actually one part of your immune system that is attacking cell tissue.
So then we got to understand what the immune system is just a little bit.
So bear with me. This is really important. Put your flaky cap on.
Your immune system has two major pieces to it.
Have some other pieces. We're going to talk about two major parts of the immune response.
So if I have five probably in this rule that somebody brings a cold virus on me
and that cold virus goes into my system and starts circulating around my blood
and it reaches a certain point, it's going to stimulate an immune response.
Hopefully, if I'm healthy enough, it's going to stimulate an immune response.
There's two sides of the immune system.
There's the immediate response system and that's called the TH1 side of your immune system.
So your TH1 side is your immediate response, your cellular response.
Then you have what's called the TH2 side.
What I'm exposed to a virus, or when you're unconditionally exposed to line pathogens,
you've fired a TH1 side. So this TH1, TH2 really holds a balance.
It's never perfectly balanced, but it's always fluctuating like this,
because we're always exposed to pathogens, right?
So you can't touch anything, you're reading anything, you're not reading a pathogen.
That's going to go into your body and your immune system kills it.
Your TH1 side is the side that initially fires.
So the TH1 side, we can put it into a car too.
They are circulating through your blood with machine guns.
They are your marine corps. They are the killer cells.
They're the macrophages. There's a whole bunch of different chemicals in that TH1 response,
different, what are called chemokites and cytokites, that will fire against a pathogen and kill a pathogen.
They do one thing, and they do it well. They kill nits. That's all they do.
So they are looking for a fight, and they are going to find something to kill, and they're going to kill it.
So they are kept in balance by the TH2 side.
The TH2 side does some killer cell response, but very little.
The main responsibility for the TH2 side of your immune system is to balance out the TH1 side and to make antibodies.
So, real case scenario, I'm exposed to a cold virus by TH1 side fires and kills it.
It goes back into balance, and I never knew I was exposed to a cold virus.
It's a really bad cold. Fires can't kill it. Your body kicks in, some more cytokites.
Fire is a little bit higher, kills it, goes back into balance.
It's still really good, right today, but I'm fine again.
It's a really bad flu. Fires can't kill it, can't kill it, can't kill it.
Fire is this huge TH1 response. I got a little fever, I don't feel good.
So I have a fever, yes, I'm going to fever. I'm going to go home a few seconds.
That's what a fever is. It's a hyper-TH1 response.
So, it's trying to kill this virus. It can't kill the virus.
After about 24 to 48 hours, your body suppresses the TH1 response.
Fire is a TH2 response. The TH2 side of your body is kicking it here.
Their job is to, if we can cartoon it, this is the Marine Corps. This is the FBI.
So, their job is to, all right, we got to do surveillance.
We got to figure out what these guys, the Marine Corps is trying to kill.
And we got to take it with some fluorescent tape.
Call it an antibody. There it is, it's Borrelia.
Let's take it with some fluorescent tape. Let's make an antibody against it.
So, we're going to make antibodies against this Borrelia, right?
That this side suppresses the TH1 side fires again.
Oh, there you are. It can kill it.
So, if it was by flu, I got this flu.
Could it kill it? Had a fever. Went home sick. It didn't feel good.
Late in bed, H. I could soup.
That TH2 side fired. Banned antibodies against this influence of virus.
That TH1 side fired again by the end of that night.
It was able to kill all that influence at L because it was all taped with these nice little fluorescent antibodies that tagged in.
So, it could see where it was supposed to shoot. It's killed it.
It goes back into balance and it back at work the next day.
That's a healthy immune response.
That's not at all immune disease.
That's what happens when we get sick, hopefully.
Problem comes in is that if my TH1 response fires against a pathogen.
And it can't find the pathogen because it is something like line pathogens that have the ability to hide within the cell.
And by TH2 response fires to try to find it and tag those line pathogens and can't find it.
The TH1 response fires. You go through this cycle a few times.
Maybe over the course of days at worst. Usually buds.
You start making antibodies against things you shouldn't make antibodies against.
Here's the, let's put it in a car too. Here's the FBI.
We do not figure out what these Marines are trying to kill all the time.
But we know it's somewhere here in the brain.
So, let's start making antibodies against these neurons.
Then, when the TH1 sign fires, it starts destroying your own cells.
That's an autoimmune disease.
So, an autoimmune disease. When your body is destroyed, it's up.
Well, it's when your TH1 or TH2 response of your immune system is killing your own cells
because you're making antibodies against your own tissue because some order that vicinity there is a pathogen that has not able to be found.
Does that make sense?
I have Hashimoto's disease, low thyroid, but doctors said I have Hashimoto's disease.
That means you're making antibodies against your thyroid.
So, I got to be able to sit through the rest of my life.
Well, you probably do have to be able to sit through the rest of your life because you have Hashimoto's disease.
Did your doctor ever ask, what is the antigen?
The antigen is that which the immune system has turned out against.
How are we going to get rid of this antigen?
Are you talking about the TH1 neurons?
Are you talking about the TH2 neurons?
Did they ever ask these questions?
And usually the patient goes, the faintest day you were talking about.
You always ever told me about this at all.
Does anybody heard all this before?
You guys are specialists in this yet?
No. You need to read the help of my body to kill you people.
This is where I outline what an autoimmune disease is.
And if you are asked that acute infection with Lyme,
and you are not in that, I can control my Lyme with herbals.
Then there's a pretty good chance that you're in the, I have autoimmune disease
and nobody's ever told me that.
My Lyme has gone intracellular, not only in Lyme joints, not only in Lyme.
Cerebellum, not only in my frontal lobes, not only in,
not my body is making antibodies against those cells.
And every time my immune system flares, it's killing me.
Literally.
So honestly, I have doctors that call me weekly,
at least.
Hi, I got a patient.
I can't figure out.
They got this and this and this autoimmune disease.
And I have a lot, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And they're getting worse.
What should I do?
Well, maybe take them off, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
If my question is, what's the antigen?
Are they T-H-1 or T-H-2 dominant?
I have no idea.
Okay, well, do you have no business training them?
Sorry.
If the person has no Lyme disease, I know I am Lyme disease.
That's not a question.
And they have these neurological symptoms,
symptoms that are abated through taking some herbals
or something like that.
And they're in the autoimmune phase.
Then you have to find out some of these answers
if you're going to help this patient.